PROFESSOR: All right.
Let's get started.
So we're continuing on
the theme of linkages.
And just a brief recollection
from last time-- and also
changing definitions
a little bit
and throwing away some
details we won't need-- we
have the idea of a graph, which
is just vertices and edges.
And then if we
added edge lengths,
if we put a number
on each of the edges,
we've got what we
call the linkage.
And then if we actually embed
that picture into the plane,
or into 3D, or whatever
space we're working in,
into d-dimensional
space, then we
call that a configuration
of the linkage.
And in general, there might
be many configurations
of one linkage.
If it's going to
fold or move around,
there is infinitely many
configurations of a linkage.
And what today is
about is basically when
there's only one configuration,
versus when there's many,
at least locally.
So this is the
concept of rigidity.
So if we have some
linkage configuration--
some configuration
of some linkage--
then we call it
flexible if it can
move from that configuration
in a non-trivial way.
So we want a non-trivial
motion starting
from that configuration.
And you'll notice that in my
definition of linkage here,
I did not specify that
some of the vertices
could be pinned to the
plane or pinned to 3D,
because we needed
that a lot last time.
A bunch of our gadgets had fixed
vertices-- pinned vertices.
I'm going to throw that
away, and the price
I pay is that whatever
linkage I build
can float around in my space.
And so I need to add this
non-trivial specification
to say that it's not
just a rigid motion.
It's not just a translation
and/or rotation.
That's rigid motion.
So you ignore translations
and rotations, for example,
by pinning.
But you can also
just see-- what are
all the motions I
can do from here?
If it's just in 2D,
if it's just the three
dimensions of I can
translate in two ways,
and I can rotate in one way,
then we don't call it flexible,
we call it rigid.
And today is all about
distinguishing rigid scenarios
from flexible scenarios.
And yesterday-- or
last class-- was all
about making things
flexible, and making
things flexible in
an interesting way
so that we computed
some polynomial.
Today, we're really
interested in the case
where we can make things rigid.
There are some places,
some situations,
where you want
things to not move,
like you're building a building.
Unless you're really
cool and you're
making a reconfigurable
building,
you want it to not move.
You want it to be rigid.
And so some classic examples
of this are the truss.
This is a standard planar
truss of some nearby bridge.
I have another truss
for the architects.
It's an octet truss-- or at
least various sections of it
in the Brussels airport.
You see these a lot in airports,
especially in ceilings.
And trusses all over the
place, especially in bridges.
And they are rigid linkages.
You've got vertices,
you've got edges.
In principle, they
could hinge there,
though they're not usually
designed to allow hinging.
But the point is even if
they are allowed to hinge,
it will be a rigid 3D
linkage configuration.
And these are very
simple examples
we would like to generalize to
understand the general picture.
Turns out, the
general picture in 3D
is not really well understood.
It's quite complicated.
But in 2D, which is what
we'll be working in today,
there's a very good answer,
and it's very clean,
and you can characterize
all the good rigid 2D
structures to some extent.
Let me elaborate a little bit.
One annoying thing
about rigidity
is that it depends on the
configuration, not just
the linkage or the graph.
So let me draw you a picture.
Suppose we have a
rigified square.
I'm going to work
in two dimensions.
Add some triangles.
So this thing is rigid.
A bunch of triangles
in the plane.
And let's say I do
that, verses-- and I'm
going to allow crossings here.
It doesn't really
matter too much.
If I draw this right-- and
I've done a little better.
It's easier when I have
a grid-- my graph paper.
In this situation,
the configuration
should be rigid, because
this part is rigid,
and these three
bars are held taut,
because these vertices
are effectively
pinned to the rest
of this framework.
And this is at full length.
You can't really hinge here.
Whereas if I flip this triangle
through that vertical line,
flip that over, I
get this triangle.
And I did the same thing
for the other triangle.
I didn't have to.
But now, suddenly-- and you
can't do that by a motion.
But if I consider this
other configuration
where that's the case,
then suddenly these guys,
which have exactly the same
lengths as they did before,
have some slack, and
now you can think
of this as a quadrilateral
which can flex separately.
So this guy's flexible,
and this guy's rigid.
This is annoying,
because we'd like
to-- think of a truss,
or something like this.
You don't think about
exactly how it's drawn.
You just think, oh, well,
there's this structure.
It's got vertices.
It's like squares
with diagonals.
Does it work if
they're skewed squares?
This presumably works.
We think, oh,
triangles are rigid.
It shouldn't matter
exactly how they're drawn.
And it turns out,
most of the time,
it doesn't matter
how they're drawn.
This is kind of a
very special case,
and I want to
formalize that notion
of "special case" and
"most of the time."
Because in particular, if I
gave you a particular linkage
configuration, and I
ask you, is it rigid?
As I mentioned in the last
class, this is coNP-hard.
So almost certainly
there's no good algorithm
to tell you whether
a given linkage
configuration like this--
versus this-- is rigid.
That's disconcerting,
because I want
to have a good
characterization of rigidity.
And this is true, even
in two dimensions.
So we're going to change
the problem a little bit
so suddenly it becomes easy.
We're going to be a
little bit less precise.
We're not going be able to
distinguish between this
and this, but almost
all the time--
like if this thing just
had a little bit of slack,
it would be flexible.
So we're going to ignore
the fact that occasionally
this thing is taut, and most
of the time, this picture
would be flexible most
of the ways you draw it.
All right.
This is the idea of
generic rigidity.
We've talked about
generic situations
before in a single
vertex piece patterns.
We said, well,
generically, no two angles
are ever going to be
the same if we just
sort of perturb
everything a little bit.
We're going to take
the same idea here.
And so, for example,
no two edge lengths
are going to be
the same, but we're
going to assume a lot more
than that to make life easier.
The general goal is to
think about the graph-- not
the linkage, and not
the configuration.
I want to say that
rigidity is usually
a property of the graph.
Most the time, it doesn't matter
what your edge lengths are,
it doesn't matter
exactly how you draw it,
it just matters how
things are connected.
Are they triangles?
What is that
combinatorial structure?
The geometry falls out of it.
I need one term so I can talk
about graphs in a realization.
This is just shorthand.
It'll make my life a lot easier.
It's a configuration of
a linkage of the graph.
We have three levels.
The graph, which is just the
combinatorial infrastructure,
linkage, where you add
the edge lengths, and then
a configuration
where you draw it.
I'm going to jump all
the way to the end
and say, if I
start with a graph,
I want to go all the
way to a configuration.
That's a realization.
And so you can think
of a realization
as just some mapping.
It looks exactly
like a configuration.
Just forget about
the edge lengths.
You can put the vertices
wherever you want,
because you haven't
said what the edge
lengths are supposed to be.
So by taking a graph and
drawing it in the plane--
this is going to be our
situation-- you can compute
what the edge lengths
become, and then see,
does it flex given
those edge lengths?
So as soon as you
draw in the plane,
the edge lengths become fixed.
But before that, they're
free to be whatever you want.
You just embed every
vertex into the plane,
and you get a realization.
And now I want to
define the notion
of a generic realization.
And this is a subtle notion, and
it's a little tricky to define.
So I'm going to
give the intuition.
And I will give a definition--
we'll see another definition
next class, in fact.
But it's a pretty intuitive
notion, especially
the way I'll be using it.
I want to somehow
avoid things that
are rare-- degenerate
situations.
And mathematically, that means
lower dimensional situations.
In general, a
realization-- remember,
we can think of it as a point
in d times n dimensional space.
If n is a number vertices,
d is the dimension of space
that they live in.
Then we could just write
down the coordinates
of every vertex separately.
And the realization
space is just that.
You can do whatever you want.
So we would like to throw away
lower dimensional subspaces
of that that just
make our life easier.
So for example, I'd like to say
no three points are co-linear.
So if I take three
points in the plane,
it's pretty unlikely they
lie on a common line.
It happens with probability
zero if I had random points.
Even if I didn't
have random points,
I just take arbitrary
points and then perturb
them a tiny bit in a random
neighborhood-- little epsilon
disk-- then with probability
zero, they will be aligned.
So I can say a whole bunch of
things like this, maybe no four
points con-cyclic, which
means lies in a common circle.
You know, Latin.
In 3D, you'd assume no
four points are coplanar.
All these sorts of things.
In general, what
we can throw away
is any non-trivial
rational algebraic--
how many adjectives
can I get in here?
I think that's all
of them-- equation.
You can, for example,
write the fact
that three points
lie in a common line
as a polynomial with
integer coefficients--
or definitely
rational coefficients.
And generally, you take
any polynomial you want,
it explains some
geometric property.
If it has rational coefficients,
and it's nontrivial,
meaning that it's not always
true-- so sometimes it's true,
sometimes it's false.
That's all I mean
here-- then you
can just-- suppose
that doesn't happen.
Because if you have
an equation, that
describes a lower
dimensional space.
You start with d
times n dimensions.
If you add a constraint on the
coordinates of some vertices--
over here we have
all the coordinates
of all the vertices.
That's what we're thinking of.
You take any
polynomial over those.
If that holds, then
that was degenerate,
and you can throw that away.
And it may sound weird,
because there are infinitely
many of these equations,
but for the mathematicians,
they're only countably many.
So if you take these spaces,
you take a whole bunch
of lower dimensional spaces
times countable number,
it's still lower dimensional.
And so you can afford to
throw away all this stuff.
If that doesn't make sense,
don't worry about it.
I will tell you various
times when we're just
assuming that we're generic.
It'll seem like magic,
because whenever
I get into a situation I
don't like, I'll just say, oh,
but that's not generic.
And we move on.
But this is the formal
version that makes that safe.
We'll see another version
that's a little more intuitive
next time.
But we need other concepts.
So this it implies that
degenerate situations
are lower dimensional.
And what other good
facts do we have?
So lower dimensional
means this is
going to happen with
probability zero,
if you perturb your
vertices a little bit.
So in particular,
this scenario-- this
is sort of the generic picture,
where there's some slack here.
This is extremely rare,
because in particular, we
have four points co-linear.
And that's not going to
happen in a generic situation.
So we would say that this
graph-- a bunch of triangles,
plus these three bars
connecting the endpoints--
is generically flexible.
Most of the time,
it will be flexible.
And fun fact is
that for any graph--
and this is not
obvious, but it's
true-- it's either generically
rigid or generically flexible.
Generically rigid means that all
generic realizations are rigid.
And generically flexible
means all generic realizations
are flexible.
I'm going to start abbreviating,
because these adjectives get
really long, especially
with the adverb form.
So when I said
rigidity is usually
a property of the graph,
this is what I meant.
Either you take all the generic
realizations of your graph,
and they're either all
rigid or all flexible.
There's going to be the lower
dimensional subsets where
maybe it's the other way around.
I'll give you some
examples of that.
So here-- what the
heck did I draw?
That's funny.
One of the edges moved on me.
If I take a picture
like this-- OK,
this is flexible, because
I have a quadrilateral here
that can flex independent
of the triangles.
But suppose I add a bar between
this vertex and this vertex
which somehow connects the two
sides of that quadrilateral.
When this special
case, the way I
drew, where these triangles
are identical and this
is a nice rectangle,
this thing is flexible.
You take this triangle, and
I want to flex the quad,
so if I rotate the whole thing
like this-- I think it works.
It twists at the same time.
Yeah, it's a little hard to see.
But because these
guys are all parallel,
this thing can keep them
all parallel, I think,
and keep all the
distances the same.
AUDIENCE: All of them are
parallel and the same length?
PROFESSOR: All parallel
and the same length.
It's necessary for this to work.
But you take a generic drawing--
if I perturb this at all,
it will be rigid.
so this is rarely flexible,
but generically it's rigid.
And I have an example
of the reverse.
The way I've drawn this, where
all these guys in extension
meet up, and all these guys
are parallel, and so on,
you can check--
it's a little hard
to see-- but it's rarely rigid.
In this case it's rigid, but
generically, it's flexible.
I wouldn't take this on faith.
For me to check this, I had
to constructed in Cinderella,
and then see that it moves.
And when these things
are almost parallel,
it moves just a little bit.
And you can see that
in the limit, when
all these things line up
nicely, it doesn't move at all.
The point is that there
are these exceptions.
That's all you need to believe.
But most the time, we're
going to get the right answer.
And so, the rest
of this class is
about characterizing when
a graph is generically
rigid or generically flexible.
It's a nice problem,
because it just
depends on the
combinatorial structure,
but occasionally, it will
give the wrong answer.
If you've set things up
with very special geometry,
it might be the
other way around.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is it fair to think
the rigidity is happening right
before it no longer works?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Right.
The rigidity is kind
of happening right
before it breaks.
In some sense, there is a
nontrivial motion there,
it just happens
to be super short.
It's hard to define
that formally,
but intuitively, that's
what's happening.
And you can think of this thing
as being a little bit wobbly,
but not technically flexible.
There's actually a formal
notion of wobbly in the rigidity
literature, which we probably
will talk about next class.
Would this be wobbly?
Probably.
I'd have to think about it.
Wobbly is a computable notion.
It's nice.
So rigidity theory is
actually pretty old.
In the mechanical, structural
engineering worlds,
it goes back to Cremona
In the 17th, 18th century.
The mathematics
even is pretty old.
The next big theorem we'll
talk about is from 1911.
It's probably one of the
earliest formal mathematical
treatments, and it started to
address exactly this issue.
In two dimensions,
which graphs are rigid,
which are flexible
in the generic sense?
It's become pretty popular and
interesting in the last 10,
20 years, and a
lot more action--
a lot more theorems and whatnot.
Today we're going to talk
mostly about old things.
Next class we'll do some newer
things in the rigidity world.
I got interested in rigidity
because it turned out
to be really important
for folding linkages.
Not just telling whether
a linkage is rigid,
which is important for things
like building rigid structures,
but for actually folding
things and showing
that you can fold the linkage
from any configuration
to any other.
Turns out rigidity is
really useful for that.
And that's not at all obvious.
It's kind of a surprise,
and a fun surprise.
We'll be talking
about that next class.
Today, sort of classic
stuff-- understanding
when 2D graphs are rigid.
I'll give you an idea
why 3D is much harder.
OK, we need one more notion.
This is a real long-winded
thing-- minimally
generically rigid graph.
So the new addition
here is minimally.
This is going to be some
generically rigid graph,
and it also has
the property that
removing any edge makes the
graph generically flexible.
So it's minimal in
the sense that I
can't get rid of any edges and
still be generically rigid.
So the idea is,
let's characterize
minimally generically
rigid graphs.
If I can characterize those,
then the generically rigid ones
are just those plus
some more edges.
You could throw in
extra edges-- it only
makes things more rigid.
It's more constraints.
But I'm really interested
in the boundary
between generically region
and generically flexible,
and this is exactly the
boundary on the rigid side--
just barely rigid.
So first thing-- if you've
done structural engineering,
this will start to
look familiar-- is
how many edges should a
minimally generically rigid
graph have?
And we can think of this in
a very intuitive way, which
is-- let's see.
If I don't have any
edges, every vertex
can float around separately.
So the number of
degrees of freedom--
the dimensionality of my
realization space, in fact--
is in two dimensions
two times m.
I'm going to do to 2D first.
Every vertex has two
degrees of freedom.
Now I would like to reduce the
number of degrees of freedom
to what number?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero.
It's often a good answer, but
sadly not the right one here.
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: Two.
Close.
AUDIENCE: Three.
PROFESSOR: Three.
Right guess.
We'll just keep trying
all the integers.
I mentioned this at
the very beginning
that if the best
we could hope for
is that there are three
degrees of freedom,
we'll never be able to get
rid of the two translation
degrees and the one rotation
degree in two dimensions.
In general, it is d
times d plus 1 over 2
is the number of dimensions of
rigid motions in d dimensions.
And here we start with dn.
So that's in d dimensions.
This is really how many
edges you should have,
because if I have
exactly 2n minus 3 edges,
I will have started with
2n degrees of freedom.
Every edge that I
add is one equation,
so it should reduce
my dimension by one
in the generic sense--
it's a generic case--
and the best I can hope for
is to get down to three.
If you put in more edges,
you won't get any more rigid.
I mean, you'll still be rigid,
but if I want the minimal case,
this is really the
best I should hope for.
And this is just a rough sketch.
This is proved more
formally in the notes here,
but this really
is a formal thing.
Again, if you take some
polynomial equation,
most of the time
it's going to define
a space that is one
dimension lower.
So in the generic situation,
every equation you add
will remove exactly
one degree of freedom.
There are rare scenarios
where it doesn't remove any,
and they're rare scenarios
where it removes more than one,
and I have some
pictures of them here.
But most of the
time, this is right.
And we are in the
generic case, so most
the time is all we need.
So this gives us an idea.
And about how many people have
heard of 2n minus 3 before
in this structural
engineering context?
A few.
And sometimes, people
end the story there.
But this is not enough
to be generically rigid.
This is a necessary condition,
but it's not sufficient.
And you can check
all these examples.
It should match up.
I haven't checked them myself.
All right.
Let's start
characterizing this thing.
We're going to see two
characterizations of minimally
generically rigid graphs.
First one is very intuitive,
nice to work with by hand,
but doesn't-- at least
as far as I can tell,
it doesn't turn
into an algorithm.
I think we've tried in
past years, but it has not.
And the other one
is more algorithmic,
but a little bit hard to intuit.
So this is what both
theorems look like.
A graph is minimally
generically rigid in 2D
if and only if-- for Henneberg,
this is from the 1911 result--
it can be built.
Oh, by the way.
Maybe the reason people
haven't seen 2n minus three
is because they're
used to the 3D case.
There it's 2n minus 6.
How many people have
seen 3n minus 6?
Same people.
All right.
Thought I'd try.
You guys should take
structural engineering.
So this is the form
of the theorem.
The idea is we're starting
with a single edge connecting
two vertices, which is
minimally generically rigid.
All it can do is
rotate and translate.
And the claim is whatever
you want to build,
I can build it using just
two types of operations.
First type is I take something
that I've already built.
I add one new vertex,
and I attach it
to two existing vertices.
So everything in
the circle is old,
and the new thing is that
vertex and those two guys.
AUDIENCE: Everything
is old and rigid.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is something
that you could already
build from this-- I
mean, in particular,
that will be minimally
generically rigid.
But that's not what
we're saying right now.
You start from the edge, and
you just keep doing this.
So I can turn it into a
triangle, for example.
Just keep taking things that
I already know how to build,
add one vertex and two edges.
The other type of
operation, I take
something I've already built.
I take three of the
vertices in there,
and there's already an edge
between them-- at least one.
There might be more.
And I add three edges
connecting to a new vertex,
and I delete that old edge.
So I add three, I remove one.
Either I add two
and remove zero,
or I add three and remove one.
This should make
sense, because if we're
going to get about
two edges per vertex,
this is just the starting case.
If I want two edges
per vertex, I really
should only be adding two edges
for every vertex that I add.
So these are two
things you could do.
And you could imagine
a more complicated ones
where I add four
edges, remove two.
You don't have to
worry about that.
You only have to worry
about these two scenarios.
That's enough to
build everything.
Maybe we can do an example
before we prove this theorem.
I'm not going to
prove all the parts.
I'm going to give a sketch.
In particular, to prove
it, I need technology
that we'll develop next class.
So it's a little hard to
do in a self-contained way.
But let's start with
an easy example.
You may remember this one.
When I drew everything
parallel and the triangles
were identical, then
this thing was flexible.
But most of the time,
generically, this is rigid,
and we can prove that by
doing these operations.
So somehow I start with an edge.
I have to do operations
to end up here.
That's a little hard to-- yeah.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Does the
removed edge have
to be between two of
the three vertices?
PROFESSOR: The removed edge
has to be among those three
vertices.
And there might
be more than one.
You would just
remove one of them.
You get to remove
whichever one you want.
Good question.
So if we were lucky
and adventurous,
we could just try going here
and hope that we end up there.
But we don't want to draw all
the possible things we could
make, because
that's all minimally
generically rigid graphs.
It's a lot easier
to think backwards,
as often the case in puzzles.
If I want to make this, what was
the last operation that I did?
It must have been
one of these two.
And every vertex here
has degree three,
has three incident edges.
So probably it was
a Type II operation.
So there's going to be
a Type II operation that
results in this thing.
Let's say, I don't
know, this vertex.
And here I still have to
be a little bit lucky,
but it's not quite as lucky.
OK so I'm going to
try not to cheat here.
So we remove that
vertex, and we also
remove some edge
among these guys.
So I'm going to guess
that I removed that edge.
I think that'll work.
I have to be careful.
I could have removed this edge.
There are two cases.
I'll explain later what
we need to check here.
Well, now I see a
nice Type I operation.
I'll just get rid
of that vertex.
Good.
So Type I operation.
I'm left with this, and I see
two more Type I operations.
I'll do them one at a time.
Ta da.
I think that's right.
We can play it forwards
just to double check,
but I started with an edge.
I added one vertex connected
to the existing two.
I added another vertex
connecting to two existing.
connected to two existing.
And then the tricky one--
I added this vertex here,
I connected it to these three,
and I removed this edge.
So because this works
forwards, this theorem
tells us that graph is
minimally generically rigid.
Now we have a way to test.
Now, the algorithm
is a little tricky,
because I had a choice here.
In this case, it didn't matter.
In the notes, there's
an example where
if you do the wrong
choice-- you go backwards
and you add in the wrong
edge-- it doesn't work.
You don't become minimally
generically rigid, essentially
because one part
gets too many edges,
and another part has too few.
Here, I got it balanced,
and it worked out.
And when you're good
at visualizing these,
this is an easy way-- like
on your problem set two--
this is an easy way to check,
to prove to me that things
are minimally generically rigid.
Just have to be
a little careful.
If you fail, and you fail to
get back to start in this way,
that doesn't tell you much.
You just may have messed up.
You may have made the
wrong choice along the way.
But when it works,
you know that it
works, because you
can play it forwards.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
By forward, I mean starting
from the single edge
and following the arrows in
the way that they're pointing.
So going backwards is a little
bit of a lucky black art,
whatever.
But once you succeed, you
can play it forwards and say,
oh yeah, that clearly works.
Another question.
AUDIENCE: Do you know if it
matters whether you do Type I
or Type II operations
first, if you have choices?
PROFESSOR: Does it matter
Type I versus Type II?
I don't think it matters in
general, just with Type II,
you have to be careful.
Type one, I like
to do immediately,
because there's no choice.
You just do them.
Type Is are always safe.
Type II, it depends which edge.
And I should call these
anti-type II operations
when you go backwards.
Anti-Type II, it depends
which edge you add.
So I like to do Type Is
whenever I have the chance.
All right.
Let me sketch a proof
of this theorem.
There are two directions
we need to prove.
We need to prove that if
we build such a thing,
it is minimally
generically rigid.
I'm going to start with that.
And the other one
we need to show
is that everything can
be built in this way.
The first direction
is not too hard,
although it's still not trivial.
And this direction works
in any dimension, in fact.
It doesn't need to
be two dimensional.
It's the other
direction that's harder.
So let's suppose I have a
generically rigid graph,
and I do a Type I operation.
And I get a graph call G prime.
I claim that the resulting
graph will also be generically
rigid and vice versa.
So doing a Type I operation does
not affect generic rigidity.
This may be obvious, but
let me explain it to you.
There's again two directions
you need to prove.
And let's start with-- which
one do I start with?-- this way.
So I want to show that if
the new graph is rigid,
than the old graph is rigid.
An easier way to
think about that
is if the old graph
is flexible, then
the new graph
should be flexible.
Hm.
That sounds all right.
So I have G flexible
generically.
I want to show that
G prime is flexible.
So here's G-- what I called old
before-- and it flexes somehow.
And now I have this
guy that I add on.
These bars are rigid, but it
can come along for the ride.
If I move these two
points somewhat,
I'll still be able
to draw this guy.
It is defined by the
intersection of two circles,
one circle centered here,
another circle centered here.
Those two circles actually
intersect in two points.
But if I move these
guys continuously,
this guy can track continuously
along the intersection
of those two circles, except
in one special case, which
is when the three
points are collinear.
So if this is the old,
and here's my new guy,
and this is taut, and these
guys move away from each other,
then this guy fails to exist.
Boom.
But that's not generic.
So here's where I
get these genericity.
This in particular would
have three points collinear.
So that's forbidden.
So in a generic situation-- and
I should be putting generically
here-- if I can generically
flex the original graph,
I'll still be able
to generically flex
after I add the vertex.
Cool.
That's pretty easy.
The other direction-- I
mean, it's almost the same.
So now if I have
G rigid, I claim
that G prime is generically
rigid-- I should be putting
generic everywhere here-- for
essentially the same reason.
If I can't move these
vertices-- this vertex
is again defined by the
intersection of two circles.
It could be here or
here, but we're only
thinking about
continuous motions.
Motion means continuous.
I can't instantaneously
jump over here.
I have to stay right there.
These guys don't move-- and I
mean that in a relative sense.
Of course, they can
translate and rotate--
but if they don't move
away from each other,
this guy can't do
anything interesting.
So if the original thing is
rigid, the new thing is rigid.
I'll start going a little
faster, but that's the idea.
This is a start, but
what we really care about
is minimal generic rigidity.
And this is also if and only if.
If your original graph is
minimally generically rigid,
then your new graph
from a Type I operation
will also be minimally
generically rigid,
and vice versa.
So minimality is also preserved.
So this is a super
safe operation.
I won't prove this.
But it's almost the same
proof, except instead
of thinking about G, you
think about G minus 1 edge,
because that's what you worry
about in the minimal situation.
We've already shown that
the generic rigidity
part is preserved
in either direction,
doing Type I or anti-Type I.
But for minimality right here,
we want to think about
removing any edge,
and whether that gives
generic flexibility.
So we just do the same thing,
but with G minus e, and G prime
minus e, where e is
somewhere in the old part.
And it's the same argument.
And so you'd write
substitute all instances of G
with G minus e.
That's pretty old and geeky.
Probably no one knows what that
means, but you get the idea.
All right.
Now, we get to
Type II operations.
It's a little more subtle.
if I said this with Type
II, it would be false.
So life it's harder.
And this is all about the fact
that anti-Type II operations
are not unique, and you've got
to be careful in how you do it.
It does work in one direction.
If the input is minimally
generically rigid,
then the new one will be.
But it doesn't work in
the other direction.
Now at this point, I'm
not going to prove this.
This is actually a
lot harder to prove.
At least, I don't know of a
simple, straightforward proof
like this one, where
you just construct it.
The easy way I know how to
prove it uses next class.
So we're not going
to bother proving it.
It should be intuitive enough.
Certainly in thinking
about degrees of freedom
it's correct, but you've got
to be more careful than that.
I want to talk more about
the reverse direction.
At this point, by
the way, we have
proved one direction
of our big theorem.
We've proved that if you can
build something with these two
operations, it is minimally
generically rigid,
because when we start
out with an edge,
this is the base case
of our induction.
This guy is minimally
generically rigid.
And then every operation
I do, I know I'm safe,
because I start with G being
minimally generically rigid.
If I do a Type I
operation, it will still
be minimally generically rigid,
and same thing for Type II
operations.
So in that direction,
we're golden.
But I'd really like
to know, is there
some converse of three,
this third property?
And I will tell you a converse
of the third property.
Suppose I have a minimally
generically rigid graph G
prime.
And I'm not assuming that it's
made from a Type II operation
yet.
But suppose it has
a degree-3 vertex--
vertex with three
incident edges.
Then G prime is the result
of a Type II operation
of some minimally generically
rigid graph G. So this is
saying that there is hope
in working backwards.
Here I had two choices
of Type II operations.
I think in this case, it
didn't actually matter,
but in general, it matters
which one you choose.
And this is saying
there is a choice,
there is an anti-Type II
operation, a backwards II
operation, that
results in something
that is minimally
generically rigid.
And if it's minimally
generically rigid,
by induction, I
can keep going on.
And so eventually I
will get back to start.
And this is what we
need to show in order
to believe one half
of this theorem
that if your thing is
minimally generically rigid,
there is a way to
build it like this.
And the way you build it is if
there's a Type I operation--
anti-Type I operation do that.
If there's an anti-Type II
operation, do the right one.
Let the right one in.
Do the right instance of an
anti-Type II operation that
gives you something that's
minimally generically rigid.
If you preserve minimal
generic rigidity,
you know you can keep going,
because you have a smaller
graph And so by induction
you can keep going.
I'm not going to
prove four either,
because it again uses technology
we haven't yet developed.
But there's one more
part of this theorem
that we haven't proved.
This sounds great.
We do anti-type I operations.
When can we do those?
We can do those when we
have a vertex of degree-2.
Then we can get rid of it.
And what property
four over there
says that if I have a vertex of
degree-3, I can get rid of it,
and add some edge to compensate.
But what if I don't have any
vertices of degree-2 or 3?
That would suck.
So this is now the other
half of this theorem.
All right.
Well, we know by
the thing I just
erased that the number
of edges is 2n minus 3.
So just to recall,
we're assuming now
we have something that's
minimally generically rigid.
We already did a degree
of freedom analysis
to show the number edges
must be 2n minus 3.
Now, we need to somehow find
either an anti-Type I operation
or an anti-Type II
operation so that we
can go all the way
to a single edge
and find a Henneberg
construction.
Any suggestions?
People know graph theory?
All right.
On the one hand,
we have the number
of edges, and the
other hand, we care
about the degrees of vertices.
Anyone know a relation
between those two things?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Two.
Every edge contributes
two to the total Henneberg
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: If I take
the sum of the degrees
of the vertices-- sum
over all vertices--
this is really intuitive.
I add up how many edges are
incident to this vertex,
then I add up how many edges
are incident to this vertex,
are incident to this vertex.
I count every edge twice,
because it has two ends.
So some of the degrees is
twice the number of edges.
I'll write that this way.
E is the set of edges
that's the size of that.
This is called the
handshaking lemma.
It says if everyone in this
room shakes hands with everyone
else-- if I go around and
shake hands with everybody--
the total number
of handshakes will
be twice the number of pairs
of people that shook hands.
No.
If we do some set
of handshakes--
so that's the graph scenario.
So some of us shake
hands, and I count
how many handshakes
I did, and everybody
counts how many handshakes
they did, we add them all up,
it will be exactly twice the
number of actual handshakes
that took place.
That's this statement.
That's why it's called
the handshaking lemma.
This is good news, because we
know this number is 4n minus 6
here.
So what could these
degrees look like?
There's n of them.
Number of vertices is n.
That's the neat definition of n.
So on average what
could these degrees be?
They have to be less than four.
The average degree has
to be at least a little
bit less than four,
because in summation, you
get 4n minus a little bit.
So the average degree
in the summation
must be a little
bit less than four.
Now, some of them are bigger,
some of them are smaller.
But if the average is less
than four, then in particular,
there must be one
guy less than four.
Some vertex has
degree less than four.
So it could either be
zero, one, two, or three.
Two and three, we're OK.
One can't happen,
because we are supposed
to be minimally
generically rigid.
If I have a degree1
vertex and some stuff,
this guy can spin around.
It's not minimally
generically rigid.
If I have a degree-0
vertex, it can float around.
It's not minimally
generically rigid,
assuming you have
more than one vertex.
So I guess this is
the situation where
you have more than
one vertex, otherwise
you can't build it
from a single edge.
Assuming you have-- so I should
put n greater than one here.
So then you get a degree2
vertex or a degree-3 vertex.
You use either property
two or property four
to make an anti-Type I or
anti-Type II operation.
You'll still have a minimally
generically rigid graph.
You keep going.
By the end, you'll
have a single edge.
That's the only case
when you get stuck,
because actually-- see, I lied.
Here, I have two
degree-1 vertices.
That's the only situation where
you can have degree-1 vertices.
And that's when you get stuck.
You have two degree-1 vertices,
but then I have an edge.
I'm done.
Questions?
Obviously, I elided a
couple of key details here,
but other than that, it's
pretty straightforward.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What if you have
more edges than you need?
PROFESSOR: If I have
more edges than you need,
then this does not
capture such structures.
This is just about
minimal generic rigidity.
But if I have some graph
that is generically rigid,
it will be a graph I can build
this way, plus more edges.
Now, how to identify what edges
I should remove so that I could
do this Henneberg construction
is unclear at this point,
and that's the purpose
of the next theorem.
So good question.
It turns out there's
an algorithm, which
given a generically rigid
graph, will tell you
which edges you can
throw away, so that you
get a minimally
generically rigid graph.
And that algorithm uses
the following theorem.
This one is from the '70s
by a guy named Laman.
It starts the same
as Henneberg above.
Graph is minimally
generically rigid in 2D
if and only if it
has 2n minus 3 edges.
And again, I'm assuming
the number of vertices
is bigger than one.
So far, this is just our regular
degree or freedom analysis.
But I said this wasn't enough.
You something else.
Here's the something else.
If I take a subset of
vertices-- and let's say
there's k of them--
then that induces
at most 2k minus 3 edges.
So this-- again, minimal
generic rigidity.
I'm still not directly
talking about the bigger case.
We'll worry about that later.
So there's the fewest
possible edges.
That means 2n minus 3.
But now, essentially
what I want to say
is that there aren't too
many edges in any one place,
and therefore the edges
are well distributed.
So if I take some subset of the
vertices-- so here's my graph,
and I take some crazy subset--
any blob the vertices I want,
I look at what are
all the edges inside
between vertices in that set?
I don't want to have too many.
I don't want to have more than
what I should-- 2k minus 3
if there's k vertices in here.
If I had more--
for example, that's
minimally generically rigid.
If I did that anywhere
in the graph--
this has 2n minus 2 edges.
It's too many.
Or 2k minus 2 edges.
K is four here.
If I put that in some bigger
graph and the bigger graph
has 2n minus 3, and I
wasted an edge here,
that means somewhere
else, it will be flexible.
So it's a bit of
a weird condition.
You might think this should say
greater than or equal to be.
It'd be more intuitive.
That would be wrong.
The theorem isn't true when you
put greater than or equal to,
because you could
choose vertices
that have no edges between them.
There's going to
be a lot of them.
But if you make sure there
aren't too many anywhere,
then it turns out it will
be just right everywhere.
It's like three little
bears or something.
So some generalized version
of three little bears.
K little bears.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
So this is a very cool theorem.
It's not obviously algorithmic,
because it says, oh, you just
check every subset of k
vertices for all values of k.
There's exponentially
many subsets.
It's not a good
algorithm by itself,
but it turns out you can
make it into an algorithm.
I'll talk about
that in a moment.
First, we're going
to prove the theorem.
OK, I have to speed up a little.
All right.
Let me sketch this proof.
It's really easy,
because we already
have this great characterization
of minimally generically
rigid graphs.
It's just things you can
build by Type I and Type II
operations.
So if I want to show
the forward direction,
that if I have a minimally
generic thing-- i.e.
It can be built this way--
then it has 2n minus 3 edges.
Well, that we already know.
And then the other thing is
that every subset of k vertices
has at most 2k minus
3 edges among them.
So think about it here.
So maybe this is my graph.
It's produced by a Type
I operation at the end.
Well, it takes some
subset of the vertices.
Either the subset contains
this vertex, or it doesn't.
If it doesn't
contain this vertex,
then it's a subset
just in the old graph.
And by induction,
my theorem will
hold, because that's
a smaller graph.
If it's a subset that
includes this guy,
then it's whatever the
subset contains over here,
plus 2 edges minus 1 vertex.
And that just works out.
Over here, there's going
to be k minus 1 vertices,
so it'll be two times k
minus 1 minus 3 at most.
We add two edges,
we add one vertex.
That's exactly
what this predicts.
You should add two
edges for every vertex.
So that's fine.
The Type II, same deal.
But in general, I'm
adding three edges,
removing one, and
adding one vertex.
And that's again true in the
subsets, not just overall.
I take a subset containing
this guy or not.
You have to check all
the cases, depending
on whether it contains
this guy or this guy
or this guy, or not.
But in all cases, this
inequality still holds.
How's that?
It's a bunch of case work, but
all really straightforward, so
believe me.
The hard part is
the other direction.
If I'm told that this is true--
all the subsets don't have
too many edges-- then I claim I
can actually build it this way,
or I claim that somehow it's
minimally generically rigid.
And we are, in fact, going
to build it using Henneberg
constructions, using
these properties
that we proved-- one,
two, three, four.
All right.
So what do we know?
We know that there
are 2n minus 3 edges.
Hey, I already have
a great argument
for when the number of
edges is 2n minus 3.
I do the handshaking lemma, and
I know that the sum of degrees
is 4n minus 6.
Therefore, I know the average
degree is less than four.
Great.
Problem solved.
Therefore, I know
there's a vertex
of degree less than four.
It could be zero,
one two, or three.
Can it be zero?
Hope not.
How do I prove it's not zero?
I know how to prove
it's not one, think.
I have to cheat here.
Aha.
Right, right.
OK, good.
Duh.
All right.
Number of edges is 2n minus 3.
Suppose my graph
looked like this,
where there's no edges
incident to this guy.
Well, how many edges
does this have?
2n minus 3 still.
I didn't remove any.
So I've got n minus 1 vertices,
yet I have 2n minus 3 edges?
That ain't right.
So that can't happen.
Similarly here, if I
have one edge here,
then the number of
edges inside this blob--
everything except that one
vertex-- would be 2n minus 2,
I guess.
But it should really have at
most 2 times n minus 1 minus 3,
which is 2n minus 4.
Sorry, I did this wrong.
2n minus 3.
This should be 4.
This should be 5.
I'll get it right eventually.
So if I remove one edge from
2n minus 3, I get 2n minus 4.
I had the sign error.
But I'm supposed to have
2 times n minus 1-- that's
the number vertices over here--
minus 3, which is 2n minus 5.
So I have the wrong
number of edges.
In fact, it should equal.
Whatever.
At most, at most.
We know in every
subset-- here, I'm
taking a subset of
n minus 1 vertices.
I have at most 2k minus 3.
Here k is n minus 1.
So I can't have degree-1,
I can't have degree-0.
Therefore, in fact, it's
either degree2 or 3.
If it's degree-2, I'm done.
I'm happy.
If it's degree--2, then I
do an anti-Type I operation.
So that's this scenario.
If I have any degree-2
Vertex, I remove it.
And I want to
induct on the rest.
Now, what do I need to induct?
I need to know that
this property still
holds on my smaller graph.
When I remove this vertex,
I want the remaining graph
to still have this property.
Does it have 2n minus 3
edges, for the new value
of n, n being n minus 1 now?
Yeah, because I
removed two edges.
I removed one vertex.
So it still has the
right number of edges.
We've already checked that.
And I need to check that
every subset of the vertices
over here has at most
2k minus 3 edges.
That's still true,
because before I
had to consider all subsets
containing this one or not.
Now I'm just looking at
subsets that don't contain it.
So I still have the
Laman conditions
holding for the
smaller graph in here.
Therefore, I can
induct, and we're done.
And we're done because then
we conclude that the smaller
graph is minimally
generically rigid.
And then property two tells
us that this thing's minimally
generically rigid, and then
I add this vertex, two edges,
it'll still be minimally
generically rigid.
And that's what I
wanted to conclude
in the left
implication direction.
The hard case is degree three.
Again, there's more than
one Type II operation.
I already wave my
hands, claiming
that there is an operation you
can do so that the result is
minimally generically rigid.
But is that enough?
I have to think about
it for a second.
It's minimally
generically rigid.
Ah, it's not enough.
It's annoying.
That's what I thought.
I'm not surprised,
but I'm re-surprised.
Whatever.
For this theory
property to hold,
I need that the graph I have
is minimally generically rigid.
That's what I want to prove.
I don't know that that's true.
So I can't use property four.
Sucks to be me.
I'm trying to prove the graph
is minimally generically rigid.
All I have is degree-3 vertex,
and I have Laman's condition.
I don't know whether property
four applies to my scenario.
So we've got to do work.
And wow.
See what I can do to this proof.
In the degree-3 case, I want to
find an anti-Type II operation.
Presumably they're out
there, but I need a good one.
For me, good means it should
preserve the Laman condition.
So after I do the anti-Type
II, after I delete those three
edges, delete the vertex,
add one edge back,
I want this to still hold.
Now, there's
essentially two things
that could go wrong
for this to still hold.
One is you go to add an
edge, and it's already there.
If it's already there, you
can't really add it again,
and then the number of
edges will be wrong.
You always want to have
2n minus 3 as you go down.
If I try to add an edge
and it doesn't work out--
because the whole point is
I'm supposed to remove three,
add one.
If I don't actually
succeed in adding one,
it'll be the wrong number.
So first thing you
need to check is
that-- so I take
this degree-3 vertex.
Here it is.
Now it's all about its
neighbors, these three guys.
If all three of those exist,
I would be in trouble.
Fortunately, that can't happen.
This is the picture I
drew that cannot happen.
This is over-braced.
There's too many edges here.
This is a subset
of four vertices.
It has more than
2k minus 3 edges.
So by Laman's condition,
this can't hold.
Some edge must be missing.
That's the one we'll target.
So at least there's an
edge that's missing.
That's property one.
There's another thing that
could go wrong, though,
which is I go to
add in this edge,
and somehow the other part
of the condition-- the subset
property-- doesn't hold.
Now, what could that
possibly look like?
It would have to be
a subset of vertices.
It should at least contain
these two vertices.
Actually, it probably
shouldn't contain this one.
This requires some thinking.
I mean, if it contained
this one, it's no big deal.
I mean, it's got do one
more vertex, two more edges.
Who cares.
But if you just look at
one of these subsets,
then in this subset,
you're adding an edge.
That's in general a bad idea,
because if it had exactly 2k
minus 3 before and
now I add an edge,
it'll have too many edges.
That would be bad.
So somehow I want to
say there's some place I
can add an edge where there
was slack, where there
were less than 2k minus 3 edges.
And so when I add
this in, I'm OK.
It's a little tricky to argue.
What we do is
suppose-- we're going
to argue by contradiction.
If this is impossible-- so
I'm going to try for these two
vertices, then I'll try
it for these two vertices,
then I'll try for these
two-- three choices.
If they all fail, I claim
there's a contradiction.
And I will try to
sketch this for you.
So let's say there are Si-- I
have some subset of vertices
Si-- and i is one,
two, or three.
And this will turn out
to be the bad case.
Suppose that it contains--
I didn't give these labels.
This is V, V1, V2, V3.
So it's going to
contain Vi plus 1 and Vi
plus 2-- those are the
other two vertices from i--
but not V. Not the vertex that
I added, because that turns out
not to matter.
And suppose that it induces
exactly 2k-- what's k here?
Size of Si-- minus 3 edges.
It has Si edges.
If it has exactly 2Si minus 3
edges, I can't add another one.
And if this is true for
this pair and for this pair
and for this pair,
then I'm screwed.
So suppose that it's true for
all three pairs of these Sis.
Fun fact.
Let's look at all of the
edges among S1 and S2.
Let's start combining these
sets in different ways.
Speed through this a little.
Something called
inclusion-exclusion principle,
which is I have these
two sets S1 and S2.
They might overlap, who knows.
But if I count all the edges
in both of them together,
that's kind of like counting all
the edges in here-- all of Si--
and counting all
the edges in S2--
and then removing the
intersection because I
double-counted there.
AUDIENCE: It's like probability.
PROFESSOR: It's
like probability.
This is inclusion-exclusion.
It exists all over the place.
Usually it's combinatorics.
But it's not quite
accurate here,
and that's why there's a
greater than or equal to.
Because we're counting
edges not vertices,
it's a little messier,
because there's
some edges you miss, like
an edge from this vertex
over to this vertex.
You'll still count twice.
But hey, it's close enough.
Greater than or equal to.
OK?
Now, I claim this thing should
only have one vertex in it.
How the heck could I claim that?
Well, let's suppose that it
has at least two vertices.
And then I'm going to
get a contradiction.
So I guess I really mean
this-- that Si intersects S2.
I claim these intersections
have to be pretty tiny.
The reason is, if
it weren't, what
do I know about the
edges induced by S1?
Well, it's a subset, so it
satisfies the 2K minus 3
property.
So it's going to be greater
than or equal to, right?
Actually, I'd already assumed
the number of edges induced
here is exactly twice
the Sis minus 3.
So this will be exactly
equal to 2 times S1 minus 3.
It's 2 times S2 minus 3, and
then the same thing there.
OK?
But this is some subset.
As long as it has at
least two vertices-- yeah,
this should be k
greater than or one.
Things don't quite
work with one vertex,
because then it says
2 times 1 minus 3.
It should have negative 1 edges.
Ain't so.
It's got zero edges.
So you need more than one
vertex for this to apply.
But now I have some subset.
It has at least two
vertices, let's say.
So it has at most
2k minus 3 edges.
So this is going to
be at most-- it's
confusing because
everything's backwards.
Well, it's going to be
another two times the size
of this thing minus 3.
So I'm just going to
collect them all together.
We have S1, we have S2, and
the one that we just added
was S1 intersect S2 minus 9.
It's three 3s.
But this thing--
and I got it wrong.
There's a sign error.
I got two sign errors.
There's a minus here.
There's 2k minus 3.
And so this is going
to be two negative 3s,
then there's going to be
a negative negative 3.
2 wrongs make a right.
It should be 3 in the end.
OK.
Now, this thing.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: The union.
PROFESSOR: It's the
size of the union.
Here it's exact,
because we're counting
vertices instead of edges.
It's this plus this
minus the intersection
from double counting.
Huh.
So two times that size minus 3.
Hmm.
So I looked at the edges
induced by the union.
I got those at
least to k minus 3.
So what--?
Right.
It doesn't sound like
a contradiction yet.
We want it to be
at most 2k minus 3
but I think there's a
property I didn't prove yet.
Great.
All right.
So what.
Let's look back at this picture.
So if I take S1 union S2,
S1 hits these two guys-- 2
and 3-- S2 hits these
two guys-- 1 and 3.
In their union, they're
going to hit all three.
So the set is going
to look like this.
It's going to contain V1, V2,
V3, but not V. Interesting.
I know that if I
put V in, I still
have at most 2k minus 3 edges.
If I remove V, I remove
one vertex and three edges.
Three edges for
the price of one.
Or for the price
of two, I guess.
Normally if I remove a vertex,
I should remove only two edges.
If I cut out V, I
remove three edges.
Therefore, this
set that includes
V1, V2, V3 has to have slack.
It can't have 2k minus 3 edges,
because-- this should be OK.
The bigger set should
be at most 2k minus 3.
When I remove a vertex
and remove three edges,
there's going to be too
few edges over here.
Two few edges is OK.
It would be strictly
less than 2k minus 3,
and here I'm claiming
it's at least 2k minus 3.
That's a contradiction.
Now, it turns out, I'm
not done, because I
was in two levels
of contradiction.
So what this contradicts
is this assumption
that there are at least two
vertices in the intersection.
Now, I know there can't be two
It's got to be fewer.
Could be zero, but
it can't really
be zero, because S2
and S2 both contain V3.
So it's got to be exactly one.
In fact-- it's the crazy proof.
When I read this,
I was like, really?
It works, though.
You can do all of them.
This is going to equal exactly
V1 and S1 intersect S3.
You can do this for any pair.
So this is going to be V2.
So all these intersections
have size one,
and we know what it is.
So what?
Well, now if I take the
union of all of them--
there's only this sharing.
There's only three shared guys.
So I get twice the
size of all them, which
is S1 plus S2 plus S3 minus 3.
Not twice.
Sorry, just that.
Who cares.
Take all the edges
induced by those guys.
At the very least, that's
going to be-- good.
Now I see.
I think that'd
actually be equal.
But the point is they
don't share any edges.
Because they only
share a single vertex,
there's no room to
share any edges.
So these guys should be
probably equal to each other.
Edges induced by all
of them versus edges
induced by each of
them individually.
Here the whole is equal
to the sum of the parts.
And this is going to be
2 times number of S1s
plus number of S2s plus
number of S3s minus 9.
This should be equal.
We assumed that
they were exactly
the right number of edges.
So this is the usual problem.
This can't happen by the
same argument we did here.
If we include V1, V2, V3
and we don't include V,
we've got to have too few edges.
And here we're saying we have
exactly the right number.
Can't happen.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's a
slight discrepancy
between the 9 and the 3.
Sorry, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There's no 2 here.
Here I'm counting vertices,
here I'm counting edges.
So I get a 2 here.
This thing is equal
to this thing plus 3.
Ah, algebra.
I multiply the 2 by the 3.
I get 6.
It cancels with the 9.
I get minus 3.
So this says I should have
exactly the right number--
twice the size of
the set minus 3.
That can't happen.
I have to have at
least one fewer.
That's what we argued.
It's messy.
You should read the notes.
But that proves Laman's theorem.
Now, in the remaining
four minutes,
I want to tell you
two more cool things.
Three more cool things.
Great.
All right.
First thing is you can turn
this into an algorithm.
How do you turn it
into an algorithm?
It's a crazy idea.
Roughly speaking,
in every vertex,
you imagine there's two little
pebbles sitting on the vertex.
And then there's a bunch of
edges incident to that vertex.
You can assign each of these
pebbles to one of those edges.
Something like that.
You get to choose each, but
I only have two of them.
I do that for every vertex.
So something like that.
If I can cover all
the edges-- there's
a slight extra
condition-- but if I
can cover all the edge in
this way, I claim I'm rigid.
Well, not cover all the edges.
If I can get all the
pebbles off the vertices
without them hitting each
other, then I'm rigid.
I might have more extra
edges that aren't covered.
Those are the extra edges.
You should throw them away.
That's over-bracing.
It's too much to be rigid.
But if I can get all
these pebbles off somehow,
then I have roughly the right
number of edges for vertices.
And while it's not
obvious, it turns out
you will satisfy Laman's
condition in that situation.
And so it turns out to just
be a graph searching problem.
You have to push
the pebbles around
in order to get them
off the vertices.
You don't have a lot of choices
where the pebbles can go.
And it turns out to be basically
m calls to path connectivity
operations.
So I've just given two graphs.
So I'm given a
connected graph, which
is the ways that I can
move the pebbles around.
I just want to know, can
I do a chain reaction
of pebble twitches till I
get this one moved away?
So it's just a
depth first search.
Whatever.
So this cost linear time.
I think we could probably
get away with n operations
each linear time
in number of edges.
So the total amount
of time is number
of vertices times
number of edges.
M is the number of edges.
Polynomial time.
Life is good.
Open problem.
Can you do better?
But that's been around
for a long time.
We've tried it before.
Seems quite challenging.
Bigger open problem.
What about 3D?
In 3D, there these annoying
situations, like this one.
Two tetrahedra
glued along a face.
Take two-- we call this a
banana-- take two bananas.
Joined them at vertices,
the opposing vertices.
This thing is flexible, right?
You just rotate through here.
It's generically flexible.
It doesn't matter how I draw it.
You can rotate
through that axis.
But it has 2n minus 6
edges, and every subset
has at most 3n minus 6 edges.
So Laman doesn't hold.
Does the generalized version
of Henneberg's theorem hold?
We don't know.
I think maybe yes.
If you want to work
on 3D rigidity-- which
is a little scary, because a
lot of people worked on it--
I think Henneberg might
be a good way to go.
It might not lead
to an algorithm,
but at least you might get
a nice characterization.
It'd be fun.
I think Henneberg would
make a great puzzle.
By working forward not backward,
it's quite challenging.
Other fun things.
Let me tell you briefly
about polyhedra.
Polyhedra are fun, and they
exist in three dimensions.
Here's a polyhedron.
It's a convex polygon-- it's
Buckminster Fuller Geodesic
Dome in Montreal--
and it's convex.
It's made of triangles.
Is that rigid?
It looks like it.
Hasn't fallen down yet-- it's
been there for 40 years now.
Indeed, you can prove
that thing is rigid,
and this is the basis
for geodesic domes.
Turns out, if you have a convex
polyhedron-- so 3D I said
is really hard.
But this does not look
like a convex polyhedron.
So what if you had a 3D linkage
that is the surface of a convex
polyhedron and every
face is a triangle?
I mean, ignoring the
floor for a little bit,
but you can deal with that too.
Every face here is a triangle.
It may be easier to
see in this diagram.
So it's a linkage.
It's a bunch of triangles.
That thing willl be
generically rigid.
And even rigid-- never
mind generically.
You can prove this
thing is rigid,
and it was proved, roughly
speaking, by Alexandrov,
let's say, or Den--
the early to mid 1900s.
That's cool.
And that doesn't mean that there
aren't other configurations.
So here's a convex
polyhedron, and you
could triangulate
the sides also.
And there's a non-convex
realization of that.
But as long as you stay
convex, and if you move--
this requires a big jump.
And you can show that if you
have a convex polyhedron,
in order for it to flex
continuously, well, it can't.
In order to flex at
all, it has to jump
into a non-convex state.
But there's a fun
thing that happens
when you look at
non-convex polyhedra.
And it's really hard to see
this polyhedron, this dent
on the backside, but you can
cut this out and make one.
And it's a non-convex
polyhedron,
and it does have
a continuous flex.
It's a flexible linkage.
It's triangulated,
but it's not convex,
and so Alexandrov's
theorem doesn't apply.
And you can move
it continuously.
It's a flexible linkage.
Fun fact-- when it moves,
the volume stays constant.
It's called the
bellow's theorem--
it was open for many years--
by Connelly and others.
And so in fact, you take any--
not just this polyhedron--
you take any polyhedron
that can flex--
it has to be non-convex--
its volume will stay constant
throughout the whole motion.
So if you've ever
played with the bellows,
you may think this is not
true, because bellows pump air
in and out somehow.
And the theorem is well, you
can't build a bellows out
of linkages.
You could maybe build
bellows out a paper,
or a flexible material, but
if you cannot triangulate that
surface, you cannot
make it a metal bellows.
Never mind if they
exist in reality.
They are theoretically
impossible to build.
I don't know-- are
there metal bellows?
That's it.
And next time, we will talk
about more rigidity and things
called tensegrities,
which even more exciting.
And we'll see how this ties
into actually getting things
to fold from point A to point
B, not just do they fold at all.
It's all related.